I'm wearing a sweatshirt with bare feet
let's judge some red carpet fashion not
judge verbally analyzed with good
intentions the Grammys happened as we
all know the Grammys is like The Hunger
Games of all the cool weirdos that you
went to high school with
I like the Grammys because it's a circus
of trying to maintain a very cool facial
expression as to elude that you aren't
trying let's look at some of the red
carpet fashion Selena Gomez this is
beautiful Sofia vergata of that cosplay
you imagine Sophie ever got a little on
a red carpet having a flashback to her
younger self on a red carpet it's just
this photo you guys are looking good
eight jokes I should took a bunch of
glitter washi tape from Target and just
went Shoop Shoop scoop boob give me the
hoops three points Taylor Swift Ching
shut everything off I don't mean that
but we can joke like that because we're
friends
she was like friendly and a winter wind
or is coming and it's hard rock hard
how'd you get so strong she looks great
Carrie Underwood looks like she just saw
the Taylor Swift got there right before
she did and she's like ah here's my
dress Tori Kelly she looks like dandy
from Greece meets a Grecian goddess a
Grecian goddess
okay yeah we're never gonna be friends
there's so much cooler than I am Josh
Groban is there being Josh Groban happy
to be part of it this is what I look
like Josh Groban I'm the butt of a lot
of jokes but I'm cool with it
Josh Grover I kind of look like the guy
that did Lord of the Rings Josh Groban I
look like your first college boyfriend
Josh Groban for Miss PO Brad Josh Groban
great guy Bonnie McKee you look like
sexy cotton candy cool use of chestplate
Kacey Musgraves educated myself she's a
country singer she looks like country
Katy Perry your name sounds like you
could be a female wrestler or like a
character in like a Fievel goes west
movie good for you
ellie goulding looks kind of over it did
you come from a beach wedding
you look very tasseled your last name is
so fun to say Goulding's
your last name sounds like a character
from The Simpsons Golding you look like
the prettiest musician at David's Bridal
this is Bow Wow
okay this is a guy this is Sam hunt he's
also a country singer he also looks like
he's captain of the good guy football
team you're wearing a move suit how do
you think you are Tyler Oakley's dream
man speaking of Tyler Oakley look at
that it just makes me happy good for you
looking like an adult with your hair
down like that proud of you
Elle King talk about the coolest person
there you seem cool and I don't care how
many ostriches you killed for your dress
they probably just were like hey take
our feathers you're cool
Kelly cuoco is that every red-carpet
event ever oh my god you are everywhere
and I like what you wear most of the
time but you are everywhere watching you
be it all of these events makes me tired
good for you zendaya going sophisticated
businessman chic and she had maybe the
best accessory of the night a mullet and
I read that she did her own makeup for
the Grammys so like that's me rioting
Demi Lovato okay this is bringing me
back I feel slightly cooler looking at
this photo no this is cool you look a
little bit like you're from a Paula
Abdul music video a really sexy
contestant on The Apprentice fantasy
accountant The Weeknd embellish a deed
thank you guys really
okay what do you talk about like when
you wake up in the morning and you're
both I really cool and groggy I wanted
you guys to take a [ __ ] in the bathroom
how does that work out for you guys cuz
one of you is that all of them let's see
I'm also recording this video while the
Grammys are happening because I won't
have time during the week to do this
video so that's it's very likely that I
missed some people that showed up on the
red carpet while I'm shooting this video
Oh Anna Kendrick got there god dammit
Anna Kendrick and you look classy [ __ ]
mother [ __ ] Wiz Khalifa like I get this
this is being high school when I grew
like six inches when I first got my
period and none of my pants fit me
Janelle Monae always looks really cool
and especially when she's dressed like a
flight attendant lollipop kids Charlie
puth I don't know charlie I know of
Charlie he does the internet thing he
also does the music things that's very
cool he's wearing a glitter
Sedo to the Grammys you look straight
out of the icing and you know what
that's my favorite part of a cake LL
Cool J is it weird that when I see a
local jail on a red carpet for some
reason it makes me think about hi
Chrissy Teigen and John Legend shouldn't
you guys John Lennon always looks like
he's got a silly little secret also hi
Chrissy Teigen I think you're great I
stalk you on social media and you look
absolutely beautiful in this photo and
you have another life in your belly
looks like she's making sure that she
wears her white before Labor Day all of
me loved all of that Joe Sam Smith you
look like a tiny handsome owl good for
you you're looking so deep into my soul
and it's making me insecure please stop
and then Adele's there just being like
ha ha I'm Adele okay that's it for my
Grammys red carpet review I hope that
you enjoyed this if you did leave a
comment down below let me know who you
thought looked great and otherwise and
subscribe to this channel so that you
don't miss a single moment of this I
don't know lace is so sweet and then
this is like blam nothing's right I'm
done I'm out of shape
your body's really in shape but your
face looks like a cherub it feels wrong
to look at you for just long I'm torn